[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
a tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 8 octobre 2001
lille grenoble lyon et saint-etienne
passe à leur tour en zone d' alerte
maximale à compter de samedi matin à
déclarations d'olivier véran tout à
l'heure lors de son point hebdomadaire
sur l'évolution de la pandémie
le ministre de la santé en appelle à la
responsabilisation de tous
bruno le maire annonce lui un
élargissement des personnes concernées
par le fonds de solidarité
il ne sera d'ailleurs plus seulement
réservé aux entreprises de moins de 20
salariés
mais jusqu'à 50 cette discussion
aujourd'hui à genève pour trouver une
issue au conflit qui oppose l'arménie à
l'azerbaïdjan dans le haut-karabagh une
négociation dans le cadre des efforts
menés par paris moscou et washington en
présence en suisse du chef de la
diplomatie azérie 1 mais son homologue
arménien a attendu lui lundi en russie
[Musique]
j - 26 avant l'élection présidentielle
américaine après un face à face engagé
mais courtois la nuit dernière entre
colistiers donald trump annoncé cet
après midi ne pas vouloir participer au
second débat avec joe biden jeudi
prochain en cause la commission
indépendante qui a décidé qu'il se
déroulerait de façon virtuelle
coronavirus oblige son chef de campagne
précise que le locataire de la maison
blanche exige deux débats avant
l'élection
et on débute avec le point hebdomadaire
du gouvernement sur l'évolution de la
pandémie et ses conséquences alors que
faut-il en retenir
on va retrouver tout de suite notre
journaliste thomas bonnin thomas bonsoir
alors une particularité 2 ministre
s'exprimait ce soir oui une conférence
de presse commune qui aura duré une
trentaine de minutes au cours de
laquelle les deux ministres ont parlé à
peu près chacun à la moitié du temps
l'idée c'était évidemment d'associer
l'aspect sanitaire à l'aspect économique
de la crise puisque olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé était aux côtés de
bruno le maire ministre de l'économie et
des finances et de la relance alors
olivier ferrand a sans surprise annoncé
des mauvaises nouvelles pour commencer
avec une situation qui continue de se
dégrader selon le ministre de la santé
donc quatre villes lille grenoble lyon
fn passe désormais en zone d' alerte
maximale ce sera à partir de samedi
matin cela implique notamment la
fermeture des bars et des restrictions
dans les restaurants avec des mesures
sanitaires renforcés
dijon et clermont-ferrand sont pour leur
part passés en alerte renforcée et puis
enfin toulouse et montpellier il ya une
situation inquiétante dans ca de ville
et le ministre de la santé se donne
quelques jours d'observation pour
surveiller les indicateurs mais
différent qui a annoncé également que
les élus locaux avaient été consultés
pour l'évolution de ces zones d'alert
pour les villes dont je viens de vous
parler c'est évidemment en référence
notamment à l'imbroglio qui avait eu
lieu à marseille il y a de cela quelques
semaines olivier roncq a également tenu
à donner quelques points positifs lors
de cette conférence de presse il y a des
signes d'amélioration avec notamment une
inflexion positive
alice bordeaux rennes ou encore à aix
marseille propose d'écouter ou l'hiver
malgré cette situation difficile et ces
annonces difficile je tiens à préciser
qu'il y a aussi des signes
d'amélioration dans plusieurs endroits
du territoire national il faut aussi
prendre des bonnes nouvelles quand on
peut les observer signe que les mesures
que nous mettons en oeuvre pour lutter
contre la circulation du virus et que
les mesures qui sont prises d'ailleurs
par les élus locaux de même pour freiner
la diffusion du virus sont efficaces
ainsi la nièvre et le morbihan quitte
les départements classés en zone d'
alerte et on enregistre une amélioration
sensible de la situation sanitaire à
nice à bordeaux une inflexion positive
également être observée à rennes ainsi
qu'à aix marseille
je le dis tout de suite avant de crier
victoire il faut avoir suffisamment de
recul être sûr que dans la durée
la circulation du virus se réduit et que
dans la durée
l'impact sanitaire sur les hôpitaux se
réduit il n'est donc pas à date de
bascule dans une zone d' alerte
inférieurs pour les villes que j'ai
cités mais nous surveillons cela
quotidiennement et nous espérons pouvoir
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles peut être
la semaine prochaine
et puis c'est donc bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie qui a pris la
parole un ministre qui a lui-même été
atteint par le cos vide et qui a
détaillé des mesures pour et bien
protéger les salariés et les entreprises
ils vont le gouvernement va protéger les
entreprises les entreprises et les
salariés tant que la crise sanitaire
sera là c'est ce qu'a annoncé bruno le
maire ce soir avec notamment l'ajout de
75 mille entreprises qui pourront
désormais bénéficier du fonds de
solidarité alors vous l'avez compris la
volonté du gouvernement était donc de ne
pas communiquer uniquement sur des
mauvaises nouvelles mais l'information
essentielles à retenir c'est toutefois
la dégradation de la situation dans un
certain nombre de villes avec notamment
des services de réanimation qui
reçoivent à nouveau de nombreux malades
du cornât virus c'est le cas par exemple
en ile de france avec plus de 40 % des
lits de réanimation qui sont
actuellement occupées et d'ailleurs la
situation dans la région inquiète
particulièrement les autorités puisque
ce matin le directeur de l'agencé
régionale de santé
il est craindre je cite une marée très
forte de nouveaux malades dans les
hôpitaux franciliens pour autant il ya
donc aussi des signes d'amélioration et
olivero indique qu'il n'est pas pour
l'heure question d'instaurer des
restrictions déplacement en france est
une question qui revient souvent puisque
on approche des vacances de la toussaint
même si le ministre de la santé
certes ne prévoit pas de restriction
déplacement il appelle toutefois à la
plus grande prudence
merci beaucoup thomas abonnés pour
toutes ces précisions
alors nouvelles restrictions dans
plusieurs villes donc pour faire face au
rebond de l'épidémie dans le même temps
des annonces pour contenir la crise
économique ont fait le décryptage tout
de suite de ces annonces avec nous et
pour en parler nous sommes avec bertrand
legrand médecins généralistes bonsoir et
puis sur les enjeux économiques charles
beck président de la carte française est
également avec nos bons soirs alors
messieurs je vous propose de débuter
avec la situation sanitaire on le disait
le plan blanc a donc été déclenché dans
les hôpitaux d'île de france obligeant
la déprogrammation de soins de nouvelles
villes en alerte maximale dont lille
alors après cette nouvelle prise de
parole du ministre de la santé bertrand
legrand
vous avez le sentiment d'un gouvernement
qui agit ou alors qu'il subit eh bien ça
fait maintenant plus d'un mois que quand
vous m'interviewer je vous dis que la
situation se dégrade et cas un grand
nombre de patients sont actuellement en
augmentation de nombre d'incidents ce je
remarque que comme à chaque comme la
première vague et comme bien souvent on
écoute les signaux de weert qu'à partir
du moment où ça arrive à l'hôpital en
réanimation et qu'il est donc déjà trop
tard qu'est ce que le changement
d'attitude était adopté il ya quinze
jours au moment où martine aubry notre
mère faisait tout ce qu'il fallait pour
éviter les mesures qu'on aurait bien
besoin
aujourd'hui elle aurait dû il ya quinze
jours fork faire comme à nice à
marseille nice a marre et marseille où
une inflexion positive 1 selon le
gouvernement ce sont ces mesures qui
paye alors on a un problème de
communication avec vous bertrand legrand
on va donc s'intéresser maintenant aux
enjeux économiques avec vous charles
bête de nombreux secteurs professionnels
un rôle c'est prennent la crise de plein
fouet
c'est pour cela que bruno le maire ce
soir s'est exprimé également aux côtés
d'olivier vers ans et cette annonce
l'accès au fonds de solidarité facilité
est large
et accessible jusqu'à 10000 euros s'ils
perdent du chiffre d'affaires de 70 %
contre 80 % précédemment c'est un bon
ajustement nécessaire charles est
d'écouter tout ce qui va dans le sens du
soutien à la survie de nos entreprises
et en particulier les plus petites les
commerçants les tpe les pme et tous les
industriels et commerçants français est
positif
dix mille euros ça va pas forcément
permettre à tous de passer noël loin de
là le prêt est garanti par l'état c'est
une excellente mesure mais un moment
donné il faudra quand même les
rembourser aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
faut surtout le plan de relance
globalement est très intéressant mais
est très long terme c'est de
l'investissement c'est des baisses
d'impôts de production c'est des aides à
la relocalisation tout ça est très
positif mais à très court terme il faut
que la consommation et ce dernier
trimestre décisif en matière économique
pour nos entrepreneurs puissent se
passer dans les meilleures conditions
et pour ça il va falloir avoir de bonnes
nouvelles du point de vue sanitaire
idéalement des réouvertures de nos
restaurants et bars sans condition et
peu et j'espère des nouvelles
suffisamment bonne pour pour aussi
permettre la réorganisation de beaucoup
de salons dont dont beaucoup de secteurs
d'activité dépendent je pense en
particulier à l'annulation du salon du
made in france qui est le grand
rendez-vous du made in france qui devait
se tenir les 6 et 20 novembre prochains
et qui malheureusement est tendu et qui
au delà des conséquences pour l'organe
et les organisatrices elle même aura des
conséquences sur tout l'écosystème du
med-it france et je crois que voilà on
doit tous agir on peut agir
il va falloir maintenant agir sur la
demande sur la consommation justement de
charlotte et ça a pu d'ailleurs
interpellé 1 ce soir ses propos de
bruno le maire qui dit c'est maintenant
qu'il faut investir c'est le bon moment
de créer son entreprise
comment vous comprenez cet appel du
ministre de l'économie ce soir qui va
peut apparaître un peu paradoxal
finalement avec la situation s'est un
peu de la méthode coué il a raison il
faut des entrepreneurs il faut de
l'investissement les périodes de crise
sont aussi les pertes d'opportunités
ce qui est certain c'est que beaucoup
d'entreprises ont besoin de son propre
et on buzze de trésorerie et puis même
de se développer
donc évidemment que qu'il faut investir
maintenant plus que jamais parce que
c'est utile à la nation
après c'est vrai que le contexte était
très incertain quant à l'avenir mais en
moins sur des surfaces au nombre de deux
positionnements sur le made in france en
particulier sur les deux ans j'en ai eu
d'engagement d'écologie sur sur le tout
ce que tout ce que le coc vida a changé
dans nos habitudes de consommation sont
des secteurs prometteurs
charlot est ce que vous nous dites
finalement c'est que avec cette crise
elle nous permet finalement de repenser
l'économie
c'est cela mais ça passera par où selon
vous ça passera pas sa part passer
simplement des paroles aux actes
ça fait dix ans que comme tout le monde
ils aspirent que tout le monde en parle
de ces transitions de consommer made in
france de consommer local de réduire son
empreinte carbone
maintenant le sujet c'est de moins
parler et de plus agir et on peut tous
le faire à titre personnel à titre
professionnel par exemple ne serait ce
que pour donner un ordre de grandeur le
plan de relocalisation prévu par de
subventions aux usines qui relocalisent
prévue par l'état et d'un montant
inférieur à l'argent distribué chaque
année par les comités d'entreprise
ces comités d'entreprise en fléchant
vers le local et nos pme tpe
cet argent
dispose d'un plan de relance entre leurs
mains comme chacun d'entre vous disposez
d'un plan de relance dans votre
portefeuille avec votre carte bleue donc
maintenant le sujet c'est de ces de
passer des paroles aux actes et de
sortir un petit peu de cette période
roxio gêne et de consommer moins mais
mieux après à noël on a tous tendance à
se détendre sur les cadeaux qu'on a à
faire à nos proches et et et il va
falloir maintenant choisir précisément
qui on veut subventionner puisque on a
des commerçants qui ont fermé pendant le
coc vide et qui viennent de connaître
les sur les de noël successifs les
gilets jaunes et les grèves contre les
retraites
un troisième noël avec des restrictions
de sortie consommation serait tout
simplement mortel pour un tiers des tpe
qui craignent de faire de mettre la clé
sous la porte à la avant la fin de
l'année alors une crise économique on le
sait est intimement liée avec la crise
sanitaire bertrand legrand quand charles
madiba il va falloir réouverte réouvrir
les bars et les restaurants
assez rapidement puisque l'économie est
en grand danger on viens de l'entendre
qu'est ce que vous dites vous en tant
que médecin aujourd'hui c'est pas le
moment vous appelez à la
responsabilisation des français comme
l'a fait olivier ferrand oui
effectivement je suis dit j'ai un
deuxième j'ai un deuxième sont
extrêmement compliqué de vous répondre
il faut absolument réussir à
reconstruire mais l'ouverture ne doit
surtout pas se faire au profit d'une
multiplication des contacts sociaux
aujourd'hui les hôpitaux comme les
médecins libéraux sont face à un afflux
qui est très important et nous
n'arrivons plus à prendre en charge
l'ensemble des patients qui vont de
toute façon terminé à l'hôpital pour une
partie d'entre eux donc réellement ce
qu'on a besoin c'est surtout d'une
diminution des interactions sociales et
on doit prendre ces mesures le plus vite
possible car quinze jours après c'est
beaucoup trop tard ça finit à l'hôpital
parce que médecin libéral vous très
concrètement vous constaté un afflux
massif ces derniers temps ces derniers
jours de nouveaux malades
oui on est sûr on est vraiment sur
quelque chose de très difficile j'ai eu
90 acte par jour et effectivement c'est
très compliqué vous imaginez bien qu'un
cabinet de médecine générale avec deux
médecins qui fait autant du rheu
d'entrée aux yeux que les urgences de
mon territoire
c'est quelque chose de qui est
impossible à faire ça fait un mois qu'on
donne la scène et la sirène d'alarmé
aujourd'hui on le mesure on voit que ça
commence à se transférer à l'hôpital
on a eu la période où on nous a dit
benoîtement qu'il fallait que les jeunes
se contaminent et aujourd'hui on voit
bien que les jeunes contaminés ont
envoyé les plus âgées à l'hôpital fait
extrêmement gênant il faut de lutter
contre la contamination c'est la seule
chose
brest est ce que le lien entre les
médecins du secteur privé et les
médecins du secteur libéral pourrait
être penser différemment selon vous
justement pour faire face à cet afflux
de malades
je suis vraiment dans les oreilles et du
coup je suis beaucoup plus de mal à vous
répondre
il ya une grosse différence entre le
médecin libéral et le médecin
hospitalier car le arrive non au moins
quinze jours après et ne voient qu'une
petite partie une fraction infime des
personnes que nous voyons et nous sommes
en fait une vigie bien en amont et bien
mal récompensée puisque je vous rappelle
que actuellement dans les négociations
conventionnelles que nous avons il n'ya
que 300 millions sur la table alors même
que l'hôpital va avoir une enveloppe de
huit milliards d'euros
on a vraiment le sentiment d'avoir été
abandonnés et trahi par le gouvernement
alors même qu'on fait la plus grosse
partie du travail à savoir lutter contre
la propagation de l'épidémie
le maître peut être un mot on entend ces
médecins effectivement se sentir
abandonnés avec pas suffisamment de
moyens
est-ce que effectivement vous avez le
sentiment que le gouvernement met plus
de moyens sur l'économie est moins dans
le secteur hospitalier aujourd'hui
non je je je
j'aurais pas de ça évidemment que la
lutte contre la propagation du virus est
prioritaire que la santé prioritaires
après c'est toujours un sujet
d'équilibrage et d'équilibré tout
simplement par rapport à par rapport à
la santé économique aussi puisque le
chômage désindustrialisation tout ça
génère aussi un somme de pathologies
parfois très graves et mortels et puis
nos modèles sociaux notre sécurité
sociale nos hôpitaux nos soignants sont
aussi financé par des cotisations qui
sont assis sur les salaires à force de
chômage partiel et de fermetures
d'usinés délocalisations et de et de
faillite
on aura encore moins pour financer
l'hôpital et la santé donc il faut bien
voilà mesurer et est très équilibré dans
cependant dans ce principe de précaution
qui à force d'être excessif pourrait
nous faire mourir en excellente santé
mais à mourir quand même merci à tous
les deux merci à vous bertrand legrand
médecin généraliste à tour quoi merci à
vous charles veut être président mais de
la carte française d'avoir décrypter
avec nous la dernière prise de parole de
olivier ferrand et de bruno le maire est
la crise du coc vite 19 qui marque donc
de son empreinte de notre époque mais
les conséquences économiques et sociales
sont déjà visibles aujourd'hui elle
pourrait empirer
d'ici quelques années en france et dans
le monde a les détails avec mon âme ou
dès lors même face à la pandémie nous ne
sommes pas tous égaux
la banque mondiale a dressé un bilan
sombre de la situation actuelle et elle
nous touche de différentes manières les
uns et les autres
il ya ceux qui n'ont pas de souci à se
faire les plus riches selon une étude de
la banque suisse ubs la crise sanitaire
a encore accru leur fortune
d'après le rapport il y actuellement
2189 hommes et femmes qui ont une
fortune de plus d'un milliard de dollars
est leur capitale se porte plutôt bien
puisque fin juillet le total des actifs
de ces milliardaires avait atteint un
niveau record d'environ
milliards de dollars un enrichissement
due en partie à la reprise des secteurs
moteurs de richesse tels que les marchés
financiers la technologie et les soins
de santé
je vous ai parlé des riches façon à
présent à ceux qui sont aussi les effets
de la crise sanitaire mais d'une autre
manière
les pauvres eux qui se paupérise
davantage selon un rapport de la banque
mondiale la crise liée aux coville 19 va
faire basculer d'ici à la fin 2021
jusqu'à 150 millions de personnes sous
le seuil d'extrême pauvreté fixé à 1
euro 60 par jour soit le prix d'un café
chez nous par exemple l'extrême pauvreté
devrait toucher de 9,1 pour cent à 9,4
pour cent la population mondiale en 2020
alors qu'en 2017 le taux s'est élevé à
9,2 sans la crise sanitaire
ce chiffre aurait dû tomber à 7,9 pour
cent en 2020 un bond en arrière puisque
avant l'épidémie de kobe 19 les chiffres
étaient plutôt positifs
52 millions de personnes avaient pu
s'extirper du dénuement entre 2015 et
après les pauvres d'avant le coc u19 qui
voient leur situation se dégrader
il y a ceux d'un nouveau genre les
citadins les nouveaux pauvres sont plus
urbain mieux éduqués ou ans susceptibles
de travailler dans l'agriculture que
ceux qui vivaient dans l'extrême
pauvreté avant le colis 19
ils travaillent davantage dans les
secteurs des services la construction ou
encore l'industrie vite de ces nouveaux
pauvres sur dix se trouveront dans des
pays à revenu intermédiaire comme l'inde
le kenya ou encore le laos pour mesurer
la pauvreté la banque mondiale utilise
trois indicateurs pour les pays à
revenus intermédiaires locaux vie 19 les
conflits armés et le changement
climatique d'après le rapport de la
banque mondiale jusqu'à 132 millions de
personnes pourraient être paupérisée
elle d'ici 2030 en raison du changement
climatique de région seront
particulièrement vulnérables l'afrique
subsaharienne et l'asie du sud
plus globalement d'après l'étude les
effets de la crise actuelle se feront
sentir dans la plupart des pays jusqu'en
2030 en france l'année a été très
difficile pour les entreprises selon le
ministère du travail 1
trois millions d'entreprises ont formulé
une demande de chômage partiel pour 12 7
millions de salariés concernés
on comptabilise également la suppression
de plus de huit cent mille postes
selon l'insee le taux de chômage en
france grimperait à 9,7 de la population
active en fin d'année une hausse par
rapport à l'année dernière est les
pauvres encore plus pauvres les riches
encore plus riches avec la crise
sanitaire on en parle avec alexis
poulain éditorialistes alexis paulin
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors on le disait les
pauvres s'appauvrissent les riches
s'enrichissent davantage avec la crise
du coc vide cette crise au fond à ce
qu'elle a mis en relief les limites de
notre système économique où elle a
montré que les inégalités ne faisant que
s'accroître et que cette crise accélérer
ce mouvement général d'inégalités pour
la france est bien le calendrier
particulier puisque france stratégie
vient de sortir aujourd'hui son rapport
d'évaluation des mesures fiscales et il
est sans appel la suppression de l' isf
l'instauration de la flat tax a fait que
les plus riches sont davantage enrichi
60% de plus de dividendes qui ont été
versés passant de 14 milliards en 2010
est à plus de 23 milliards en 2018 et
ses dividendes et biel se sont
concentrées au sein des plus riches
les héros les 0 1% environ 38 mille
ménages ont touché les deux tiers de
cette manne financière tandis que les 0
01 % ont touché le dernier tiers en 2018
alors qu'il ne touchait que sa cinquième
en 2010 est donc on voit bien que les
réformes mises en place par le
gouvernement qui était censé aider
l'économie à rebondir
et bien non fait qu'enrichir les plus
riches qui profitent largement de ces
réformes le rapport de francs stratégie
lui ne peux pas dire si ces réformes là
ont été bénéfiques ou non pour
l'économie mais le politique justement
selon vous est-ce qu'il a les moyens
d'intervenir pour réguler davantage la
distribution des richesses
oui par la fiscalité notamment et on
voit bien que cette fiscalité qu'on a
voulu aligner avec la fiscalité mondiale
qui crée des inégalités au niveau
mondial et bien en france
elle crée davantage d'inégalités et pas
autre chose et pourtant bercy
continuer veut il veut aller davantage
le plan de relance à 100 milliards et
bien 20 milliards sont d'exonérations
fiscales pour les impôts de productivité
des entreprises
on continue dans cette logique même si
nous n'avons pas de visibilité sur
l'impact réel sur l'économie
mais dans le même temps ce choix d'aider
les plus riches n'est pas mire avec un
choix d'aider les plus pauvres
un rapport de l'insee de 2019 lui
faisait état de plus de 1.5 millions de
citoyens français passant sous le seuil
de pauvreté entre 2017 et 2018 et pour
cela très peu dead seulement 0 8% du
plan de relance un est consacré à
l'extrême pauvreté environ 800 millions
d'euros 600 millions d'euros qui sont
pour les tickets restaurant à 1 euro et
pour les aides à la rentrée scolaire 100
millions d'euros pour l'hébergement
d'urgence des plus démunis et puis 100
millions d'euros des dons aux
associations donc le politique préfère
démissionner et chargé les associations
de gérer l'extrême pauvreté
victime de des politiques choisies en
fait de la pauvreté et sur quels
ressorts on pourrait s'appuyer
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que nous a appris
cette crise
au fond cette crise nous a appris une
chose c'est que nos sociétés développées
ont su organiser au fil du temps la
solidarité c'est ce qui a permis à la
france de supporter la crise financière
de 2008 mieux que certaines autres
économies européennes
mais comme l'économie est maintenant le
seul objectif des politiques
alors il fallait redevenir compétitif
donc enlever les solidarités qui coûte
cher qu'ils coûtent trop cher elles sont
vues comme des externalités négatives
or c'est un investissement aujourd'hui
ceux qui souffrent le plus de cette
crise sanitaire ceux qui vont souffrir
le plus ce sont les plus jeunes à la
fois par rapport à l'accès à l'éducation
de plus en plus difficile et puis
l'accession à l'emploi rendu également
de plus en plus difficile puisque le
marché de l'emploi va se contracter et
que ce sont les premiers à sortir
puisque il n'ya pas pour eux l'emploi
nécessaire donc si on n'investit pas
aujourd'hui sur les plus jeunes les plus
précaires les plus démunis et bien
l'avenir risque d'être extrêmement
difficile parce que ça ne peut pas tenir
une société où les inégalités sont elles
je suis désolé à un moment les personnes
ne peuvent plus accepter une telle
différence de traitement entre les ultra
riches et les ultras pauvre et c'est les
solidarités ou
aujourd'hui qu'il faut retravailler au
niveau du politique un avenir
extrêmement difficile ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire des mouvements sociaux très
dur à l'avenir oui des mouvements
sociaux très dur un rejet total du jeu
politique même démocratique en disant si
les élus continuent de faire toujours la
même politique en direction des 1% les
plus riches des 0 1% des plus riches
alors vous avez le taux d'abstention
déjà qui est énorme
on est presque passé à un suffrage
censitaire voiliers qui se déplacent
pour voter ce sont déjà plus les plus
précaires ou les plus pauvres ceux là
ont abandonné ce jeu là mais derrière le
coup de la pauvreté est beaucoup plus
important que si on avait été des
mesures pour enrayer l'extrême pauvreté
et on ne peut pas compter seulement sur
les associations pour cela il ya bien
entendu l'éducation nationale mais il ya
les impôts les riches doivent payer des
impôts
c'est ce qui est demandé par plusieurs
milliardaires américains parce que si on
continue dans cette voie là et bien nous
serons au niveau des états unis le
système de santé système de santé
américain ou si vous n'avez pas de
mutuelle ou d'assurances privées vous
payer une fortune pour vous faire
soigner ou être pris en charge ne serait
ce que pour le quoran à virus en france
nous avons des solidarités elles sont
précieuses mais malheureusement le
personnel politique depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années n'a eu de cesse que de
casser ce système de solidarité les
riches doivent payer des impôts et les
solidarités doivent être protégés à tout
prix si nous voulons éviter la
catastrophe sociale
merci beaucoup alexis poulain je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes et
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la situation au karabagh alors que
le ministre des affaires étrangères de
l'azerbaïdjan
elle s'est rendue à genève pour une
rencontre avec le médiateur
international
et puis direction les états unis kamala
harris et mike pence ont offert un débat
musclé mais courtois en attendant le
prochain entre trump hebeisen qui
pourrait se tenir de façon virtuelle a
tout de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
le secteur de l'immobilier n'a pas été
épargnés par les mesures sanitaires
d'urgence mis en place par le
gouvernement les banques aujourd'hui
donc quand on sait qu'elles vont un peu
coupé les robinets et si elle coupe les
robinets ça va être un petit peu plus
compliqué pour l'immobilier l'immobilier
haut de gamme était la valeur refuge par
excellence celle qu'un qui a plus de 75
ans a priori l'achète pas un appartement
il le vent et comme il aura pas beaucoup
de retraite
il est assez probable qu'ils soient
obligés de vendre son actif pour
continuer à vivre
il ya un vieillissement de la population
qui fait que vous allez avoir une baisse
des prix dit aujourd'hui que c'est la
revente des campagnes contre les villes
parce que les villes souffrent
globalement tout le marché comme disent
les deux va devenir plus raisonnable les
acquéreurs vont être plus sélectifs
[Musique]
comment on devient jean louis etienne
parce que vous êtes aéro pour plein
d'enfants je rêvais de faire des
expéditions sans trop savoir ce que
c'était et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être mal ce parcours là
vous a placé dans la bataille écologique
le réchauffement climatique est une
réalité quand on va bien on a 30 cède
cantona un degré de plus de 38 en
médecine label 5 fabrique une petite
fièvre couvre quelque chose la planète l
année là aujourd'hui chacun a ses
activités impact la nature impacte notre
les questions environnementales
le risque c'est évidemment le
réchauffement climatique
mais l'autre risque c'est aussi la
réduction de l'activité économique jean
jaurès disait une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup aller à l'idéal quittant
comprenant le réel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent
françois vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche plus extrême
intensité
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france suit
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française à 12e jour d'affilée de
conflits au karabagh aujourd'hui des
bombardements ont endommagé une ville
arménienne
dans le même temps une rencontre avait
lieu dans la journée à genève les
précisions avec florian lambert une
cathédrale arménienne bombardé nouveau
symbole du conflit haut karabakh de
nouveaux tirages un badge année hors
otan ti dans la ville de cuxa ce jeudi
bakou dément et le premier ministre
arménien nicole patxi mian appelle à
trouver un compromis dans les prochains
jours notamment jeté aux jets 4 août
quand des radicaux et des terroristes
internationaux sont là
la région devient une menace pour la
sécurité du monde entier et bien sûr l
implication de la turquie une influence
il est évident que comme tout conflit
si nous souhaitons vraiment le résoudre
des compromis sont nécessaires la
turquie par le biais de son président
recep tayyip erdogan continue d'afficher
au grand jour son soutien à
l'azerbaïdjan azerbaijan en date
l'acteur ne nous voyons que
l'azerbaïdjan est extrêmement déterminé
à libérer son territoire
la turquie soutient de tout son coeur la
lutte légitime de l'azerbaïdjan pour
reprendre possession de son territoire
nous invitons tous les pays qui
défendent la justice et d'équité à
soutenir l'azerbaïdjan
ces bombardements interviennent alors
que les représentants russes américains
et français acteur de cette médiation
rencontrée ce jeudi à genève le ministre
azerbaïdjanais des affaires étrangères
son homologue arménien en lui
est attendu lundi en russe 11 au 13
octobre 2020 le ministre arménien des
affaires étrangères au rabbinat de
sakania envisage de se rendre en visite
officielle à moscou le ministère russe
des affaires étrangères accueillera des
négociations entre les deux ministres au
cours desquelles sergueï lavrov et son
homologue arménien évoqueront les
problèmes internationaux et les
questions de sécurité régionale
bien évidemment l'accent sera mis sur la
situation extrêmement difficile dans la
zone de conflit du haut karabagh
le bilan officiel depuis la reprise des
hostilités le 27 septembre dernier
s'étant de 300 à 400 morts dont une
cinquantaine de civils ce bilan sain
vers néanmoins très partiel bakou ne
souhaitant pas communiquer ses pertes
militaires 70 à 75 mille personnes dont
90 % de femmes et d'enfants ont été
déplacées par les combats information
rapportée hier par le médiateur de la
république autoproclamée du haut
karabagh à témoignages tout de suite de
citoyen arménien et azéri au coeur de ce
conflit
tout le monde est parti d'une manière ou
d'une autre après avoir passé la ville
de latchine ils ont entendu une
explosion il s'est avéré que le pont
avait été partiellement détruit par
l'explosion et les voitures ne pouvaient
plus passer
ils ont dû marcher des kilomètres à pied
ils avaient peur d'un bombardement avoir
son propre foyer
c'est la meilleure des choses même si
tout est en ruine
même s'il n'ya pas de toit au dessus de
votre tête ça reste votre terre je ne
peux plus parler
puisque nous avons l'un des plus grands
hôtels de la ville de goris nous n'avons
pratiquement pas de chambre de libre
nous hébergeons les gens gratuitement
avec trois repas par jour nous
fournissons des soins médicaux
nous invitons des médecins plus de 200
réfugiés ont été admis dans notre hôtel
autant que je sache dans les autres
hôtels il n'y a pas de place je suis
originaire de la ville d'agde dame
nous avons perdu notre maison nous
sommes devenus sans abri alors nous
sommes venus ici je ne me plains pas ça
aurait pu être encore pire
et pour parler de la situation au
karabagh nous sommes avec rahman
moustafa iev ambassadeur d'azerbaïdjan
en france ammann mustafayev merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france ce soir
alors le ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'azerbaïdjan était donc à
genève aujourd'hui pour une rencontre
avec le médiateur international sur le
conflit l'arménie n'était pas représenté
quel était le but de cette rencontre
pour l'azerbaïdjan
merci pour sa part importante est de
parler de présenter notre point de vo
pour l'audience de france à petit la
visite de notre ministre engine et la
caractère que visite de reconnaissance
pour le charger avec les coprésidents
sous le sceau de la question n'est le
sujet donc qui concerne le conflit
donc c'est une première entretien entre
le ministre raza passionnés et les
coprésidents
donc allons attendre les résultats
mais en principe donc il s'agit du
premier entretien elle pour se
rencontrer
donc
la connaissance pour échanger des vues
sur la question de place c'est donc le
groupe 2006 un composé de la france de
la russie des états unis qui est chargée
depuis trente ans de faciliter une
résolution pacifique de cet affrontement
il appelle aujourd'hui l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie à cesser les hostilités
entamer le dialogue
quelle est la position aujourd'hui de
l'azerbaïdjan sur le règlement du
conflit la pause et ceux de grandes
piliers de notre république n'a pas
changé depuis donc 1992 et ris il s'agit
de l'application des dispositions de la
résolution du conseil de sécurité qui
était adoptée en 1993 et qui est d'ordre
le retrait immédiat complet sans
transition d'autres forces armées
arméniennes qui occupent les régions de
calabar et cette région autour de retour
à la barre de la république donc notre
position est claire il n'a pas changé
donc nous changeons pas le format de
glaucome nous sommes à disponible
toujours pour soutenir les efforts des
coprésidents de soma ouvert où les
échanges de moulay a donc discuté sur
les questions de base mais la base
gentil c'est l'application des
dispositions de droit en cause on peut
parler et discuter sur le sujet de
cessez le feu mais nous ne sommes pas le
sujet principal
ces écarts iter et didier les
conséquences de ce conflit et les
conséquences sont saines occupations de
territoires à 0,90 cessez le feu si
belle nous sommes ouverts pour discuter
ce sujet mais d'abord il faut comprendre
que les indiens attendent aujourd'hui
donc le calendrier clair concrète avec
les les grandit le congrès retrait des
forces arméniennes de toutes les zones
occupées
et nous autres avons aussi les garanties
décor président donc il faut avoir le
papier donc le calendrier est signé par
l'un des jeunes arméniens et vérifiées
et signés et confirmé par les alors ne
le premier ministre arménien a fustigé
mardi l'engagement turc 1 dans le
conflit on parle notamment la présence
éventuelle de mercenaires turc est ce
que la turquie apporte un soutien
militaire ou humains ou matériels à
l'azerbaïdjan dans ce conflit
j'ai déjà eu droit de reportages donc la
déclaration de président en toc
dogan ce qu'il a dit donc nous qui
sommes nous soutenons la cervoise morale
membres nous avons une coopération très
forte avec la nature type
il s'agit de l'eca personnes à
diplomatiques politiques cg de soutien
politique diplomatique et bien plus tôt
et qui le soutient de morale exécutive
bien sûr la coopération très forte donc
militaire entre les deux pays
mais en même temps je voudrais donc vous
dire que là même un type de coopération
de la coopération avec la russie avec le
bélarus i avec le pakistan avec les
autres pays du monde y compris un nez ça
y est c'est à dire
il s'agit de la coopération qui se
déroule dans le cadre du droit
international il ce que fait aujourd'hui
et la turquie ceux qui déclarent
aujourd'hui donc le président sur les
actions les dommages les déclarations de
gourmands doute ne dépassent pas le
cadre du droit à tant d'honneur
ici il faut être très clair alors le
chef de la diplomatie arménienne doit
être lui reçu lundi à moscou par son
homologue russe sergueï lavrov qu'en
attendez-vous donc le sujet des chances
entre le ministre arménien arménien et
russe ce jeu internet
entre les deux ministres j'espère que
les responsables du régime arménienne
aujourd'hui ils ont déjà compris qu'avec
la sauvagine donc la logique de force à
la régie du muscle donc marchera
aujourd'hui je reviens d'un qu'on fasse
le jeu de base nous attendons de
l'arménie et des coprésidents le
calendrier clair qui va spécifier les
bacs avec le retrait des forces le
retrait immédiat complet et sans
condition de toutes les forces
arméniennes des ondes et de déserts
matière la région est capable de la
reprise mondiale et aussi cette région
autour de [ __ ] art n'oublions pas qu'un
début de conflit
donc cette région qui était peuple est
non seulement par les asthmatiques par
les arts mini jupe en jean et 25% de la
population de retrait bas s'était
assoupi azerbaïdjanais non seulement la
moitié des centaines de familles
heureuses des kurdes des juges les ont
été chassés de cette région
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il s'agit de
l'application des dispositions de tout
document de conseil de sécurité de l'onu
retrait des forces arméniennes sans
condition complet et immédiat lé retour
de toutes les déplacés réfugiés dans les
zones donc de leur habitation donc
initiale dans l'ordre une maison du
village natal et après on peut donc
discuter sur le sujet de futures de
cette région
merci beaucoup rahman moustafa yeves
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes ambassadeur
d'azerbaïdjan en france aux états unis à
présent le prochain débat donald trump
joe biden aura lieu jeudi prochain
un face à face que les organisateurs
souhaitent virtuel que 8,19 oblige
si le président américain malades du
coronavirus refuse tout duel à distance
son vice président et co listiers mike
pence à lui déballe tuer la need la nuit
dernière avec le bras droit du candidat
démocrate
cyrielle bruit
une arrivée tout sourire un salut aux
rares spectateurs de la salle et le
débat peut commencer dans une ambiance
particulière kamala harris et mike pence
se font face séparés par des parois en
plexiglas virus oblige
premier sujet et pas des moindres la
question de l'épidémie du coffee 19 sur
le territoire américain
une occasion en or côté démocrate pour
pointer du doigt la gestion du président
donald train mais le peuple américain a
été témoin de ce qui est le plus grand
échec de toute administration
présidentielle dans l'histoire de notre
pays
et voici les faits deux cent dix mille
personnes sont mortes dans notre pays au
cours des derniers mois plus de sept
millions de personnes ont contracté
cette maladie
une entreprise sur cinq a fermé at je
pense que le peuple américain c'est que
le président a fait passer l'amérique et
le peuple américain en premier je crois
qu'avec mon coeur je peux être fier des
sacrifices qu'ils ont faits et ils ont
sauvé d'innombrables vies américaines
alors que la sénatrice démocrate kamala
harris a admis ne pas vouloir se faire
vacciner si le vaccin est conseillé par
donald trump le vice-président
républicain lui s'est empressé de
l'accusé de saper la confiance des
américains
ue continue le fait que vous continuez à
saper la confiance du public dans un
vaccin
si le vaccin paris pendant
l'administration de trump est à mon avis
y des demies cible et sénatrices je vous
demande simplement de cesser de faire de
la politique avec la vie des gens là
dans dix neuf sujets phares qui a dominé
les 90 minutes
yo se débat tant attendu tensions
raciales écologie ou encore système de
santé les deux colistiers ont dû mener
de front ces sujets particuliers des
solutions et ce dans le calme et la
diplomatie sans pour autant éviter
quelques petits accrochages notamment
sur la question des déclarations
fiscales du président sortant oui mais
dans l'ombre aux nous savons maintenant
que donald trump doit 400 millions de
dollars et qu'il est endetté et pour que
les choses soient claires lorsque nous
disons endettés
cela signifie que vous devez de l'argent
à quelqu'un il serait vraiment bon de
savoir à qui le président des états unis
le commandant en chef doit de l'argent
car le peuple américain le droit de
savoir ce qui influence les décisions du
président de 5
le fait est que joe biden a été très
clair il n'augmentera pas les impôts de
ceux qui gagnent moins de 400 mille
dollars maroc il a dit qu'il va vous
rejoindrez la réduction d'impôt de trump
monsieur le vice président c'est moi tu
parles je parle un débat à la fois
musclé disciplinée qui contraste
nettement avec celui de la semaine
dernière entre donald trump et de weiden
les lieutenants des candidats semblent
avoir voulu recentrer leurs discours sur
les sujets essentiels de cette
présidentielle
les regards se tournent à présent sur le
prochain duel entre le président et son
challenger démocrate prévue le 15
octobre prochain
reste à savoir si celui ci aura lieu
compte tenu de la récente contamination
du président sortant est à 26 jours du
scrutin présidentiel donald trump appels
sur les réseaux sociaux à rapatrier les
soldats américains d'afghanistan d'ici
noël plutôt donc que ce que prévoit
l'accord historique signé avec les
talibans soit
alami 2021 walid ben ali le 13 juin
dernier lors de la cérémonie de remise
de diplômes de la prestigieuse académie
militaire de west point
donald trump a annoncé que les états
unis n'étaient pas les policiers du
monde ce n'est pas le devoir des troupes
américaines que de résoudre d'anciens
conflits dans des terres lointaines dont
beaucoup de gens n'ont jamais entendu
parler dossier crucial
la guerre d'afghanistan dure depuis près
de 19 ans à la suite d'un accord
historique avec les talibans en février
dernier au qatar les etats unis comptent
entamer le retrait de leurs troupes du
territoire afghan en septembre à doha
le secrétaire d'état a rappelé les
enjeux de ces négociations
nous vous invitons à prendre des
décisions qui permettent de s'éloigner
de la violence et de la corruption et de
favoriser la paix le développement et la
prospérité
mon appel aux talibans n'ayez pas peur
d'un cessez le feu personne ne vous
anéantira en irak
washington a promis de continuer à
lutter contre le groupe etat islamique
avec l'aide de l'armée irakienne
les etats-unis ont décidé de réduire
leur présence militaire en irak
d'environ 5 1200 à 3000 militaires
durant le mois de septembre
ces derniers mois les forces américaines
restent la cible de groupes
paramilitaires chiite
l'ambassade des etats-unis a été visé à
plusieurs reprises
washington a donc renforcé sa présence
dans d'autres pays de la région où elle
dispose de bases militaires comme
l'arabie saoudite ou le koweït afin de
maintenir sa pression sur l'iran enfin
en syrie près de 40% des effectifs de
l'armée américaine ont quitté le
territoire notamment le nord du pays où
kurdes et turcs s'affrontent
il est question aussi d'un redéploiement
principale mission protéger les champs
pétroliers et gaziers de deir ezzor
contre le groupe etat islamique et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
houston avec enel dougherty
coordinatrice au sein des républicains
in france c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonjour mail dougherty merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors ce
retrait des troupes américaines avant
noël c'est une décision politique
une promesse de campagne excusez moi je
n'ai pas compris mais pis je vous
demandais neil dougherty si ce retrait
des troupes américaines avant noël dont
on parlait à l'instant si c'est une
décision politique ou bien une promesse
de campagne à bram à ses promesses très
ancienne de donald trump
il a promis de réduire le nombre des
troupes américaines dans le monde alors
nous nous avons un problème visiblement
de traduction alors alors nous allons
essayer on va essayer de résoudre à ce
problème de traduction avec cette
nouvelle question
ces différents retraits soutenu par
donald trump est ce qu'il pourrait être
remis en question en cas de victoire de
joe biden selon vous oui c'est facile
donc oui il pourrait se serait possible
en a on a un problème de crédit on a
effectivement un petit problème
également de traduction ce soir je tente
cette troisième question tout de même
ces différents retraits soutenu par de
malte rome vous nous disiez qu'il
pourrait être remis en question en cas
de victoire par joe biden aujourd'hui la
présence de ses troupes est ce qu'elle
est encore justifiable et justifier au
moyen-orient joe biden renforcerait sans
doute effectivement les effectifs
et senna semble ne pas vouloir de
retrait en tout cas merci beaucoup à
vous un tel dougherty on a effectivement
un petit problème on s'en excuse
nous nous en excusons petit problème de
traduction ce soir merci à vous et neil
dougherty je rappelle que vous êtes
coordinatrice au sein des républiques
and in france et on poursuit avec le
président du conseil européen charles
michel qui s'est rendue à dublin
aujourd'hui pour y rencontrer le premier
ministre irlandais michael martin au
centre des discussions le break site
bien évidemment pour rappel les
britanniques souhaitent revenir sur les
accords conclus initialement cela a
provoqué la colère des européens
l'échéance des négociations fixé au 15
octobre se rapproche à grands pas alors
que celle ci semble être dans une
impasse
ah si aucun accord n'est trouvé
l'irlande pourrait subir de lourdes
conséquences économiques
in ancient comme dans toute négociation
de ce genre rien n'est valide est temps
que tous ne les pas des jours qui
viennent sont cruciaux c'est le moment
de vérité de monsters of truth maé mais
sais-tu simpl dit mon message est simple
lieu est pleinement solidaire de
l'irlande
et cela est particulièrement vrai en ce
qui concerne la mise en oeuvre intégrale
de l'accord de retrait et du protocole
sur l'irlande et l'irlande du nord
la situation reste très difficile il
faut faire bouger les choses pour
parvenir à la phase finale des
négociations et nous pensons qu'il y
encore beaucoup de travail à faire sur
un certain nombre de fronts anglophone
et ben existe toujours et la pêche qui
reste un sujet important de discorde
entre européens
voilà je vous propose de regarder tout
de suite à ce sujet entre ce sujet de
discorde entre européens et britanniques
1 à l'occasion d'une visite aux pays-bas
le secrétaire d'état français aux
affaires européennes clément boon s'est
montré ferme sur ce sujet a écouté les
chercheurs ne seront pas la variable
d'ajustement libre etc si ils n'ont pas
à faire les frais
et de des choix britannique il y aura un
accord à faire je l'espère nous ne
ferons pas n'importe quel prix et
certainement pas en sacrifiant les
intérêts de nos pêcheurs un accord c'est
souhaitable mais c'est un mauvais accord
qui serait le pire des scénarios est
donc nous préparons un scénario sans
accord et nous n'accepterons pas de
mauvais compromis
cet accord ne se fera pas à n'importe
quel prix cet accord ne se fera pas au
prix des intérêts fondamentaux de la
france des pays-bas de l'europe
notamment sur la pêche et dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur les
deuxièmes dernières mesures annoncées
par olivier ferrand lille grenoble lyon
et saint-etienne passe en zone d' alerte
maximale
puis direction l'europe plusieurs pays
serrent la vis face au regain de
l'épidémie comme l'italie ou le masque
est obligatoire l'extérieur du côté de
l'état hébreu les manifestations contre
les mesures de confinement et la
politique de netanyahu à prennent de
l'ampleur a tout de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qui ait des
candidats n'y a pas d'alternative on
sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit on doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie d'avoir un huitième
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et la préparer il
ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire en traîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter vert à 30% de son
pipe pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur nous
expliqué qu'effectivement le réveil va
être compliqué il va être douloureux il
ya eu un moment de très grand
relâchement et nous sommes en train de
payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
ep
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président avait décidé de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature a dû pdc y va être en partie
reste crédible partir du moment où le
présent l'économie et revient dans la
course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons plaide une malheureuse on peut
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
est libre d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de nous allons
retrouver le pouvoir gagner cette
élection et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'avons pas les
poursuivre ou des fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près d ivoire
et
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu' barral avant moi c'est fini
pour moi est ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du malheur mais
quel est le rapport avec la réducation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
il
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refera met à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait ça jamais là d'une
décision à vraisemblable pour vous ça
dépend quelle valeur on attribuait la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un départ
n'aura un débat éthique
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dont des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui jugé amadou gon
coulibaly est décédé pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession
nous estimons que les envois tara est
celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face ont pu fiction posent à
nous tant au niveau interne ou externe
qui m'a particulier en ce moment en côte
d'ivoire des violences sous prétexte
d'une manifestation et d'expression de
droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on est six mètres
est-ce que sincèrement vous êtes
certains que le scrutin du 31 octobre
sera maintenu à la date prévue
il n'y a pas de raison que ce scrutin ne
soit pas maintenu
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 8 octobre 2000 elle lille grenoble
lyon et saint-etienne passe à leur tour
en zone d' alerte maximale à compter de
samedi matin à déclarations d'olivier
véran tout à l'heure lors de son point
hebdomadaire sur l'évolution de la
pandémie
le ministre de la santé en appelle à la
responsabilisation de tous
bruno le maire annonce lui un
élargissement des personnes concernées
par le fonds de solidarité
il ne sera d'ailleurs plus seulement
réservé aux entreprises de moins de 20
salariés
mais jusqu'à 50 tours de vis en europe
face au co vide bars et cafés fermés
ville bouclée contacts sociaux limités
les mesures restrictives se multiplient
partout ou presque à madrid par exemple
le gouvernement régional demande de ne
pas quitter la villa malgré une décision
judiciaire contraire
ailleurs on y serait les restrictions
liées aux manifestations et aux prières
en salle sont prolongées jusqu'au 13
octobre
[Musique]
discussion aujourd'hui à genève pour
trouver une issue au conflit qui oppose
l'arménie à l'azerbaïdjan dans le
haut-karabagh une négociation dans le
cadre des efforts menés par paris moscou
et washington en présence en suisse du
chef de la diplomatie azérie mais sans
son homologue arménien attendu lui est
lundi en russie
[Musique]
un scrutin très scrutées celui de la
présidentielle en côte d'ivoire le 31
octobre à la mission conjointe de la
cedeao l'union africaine et les nations
unies font part de ça je cite vive
préoccupation
l'opposition qui rejette la candidature
d'alassane ouattara un troisième mandat
a lancé un appel à la désobéissance
civile qui devrait débuter ce samedi
[Musique]
le point hebdomadaire sur l'évolution de
la pandémie en france et ses
conséquences s'est tenue en fin
d'après-midi alors que faut-il en
retenir les précisions de notre
journaliste thomas bonnet ou une
conférence de presse commune qui aura
duré une trentaine de minutes au cours
de laquelle les deux ministres ont parlé
à peu près chacun à la moitié du temps
l'idée c'était évidemment d'associer
l'aspect sanitaire à l'aspect économique
de la crise puisque olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé était aux côtés de
bruno le maire ministre de l'économie et
des finances et de la relance alors
olivier ferrand a sans surprise annoncé
des mauvaises nouvelles pour commencer
avec une situation qui continue de se
dégrader selon le ministre de la santé
donc quatre villes lille grenoble lyon n
passe désormais en zone d' alerte
maximale ce sera à partir de samedi
matin cela implique notamment la
fermeture des bars et des restrictions
dans les restaurants avec des mesures
sanitaires renforcés
dijon et clermont-ferrand sont pour leur
part passés en alerte renforcée et puis
enfin toulouse et montpellier il ya une
situation inquiétante dans ces deux
villes et le ministre de la santé se
donne quelques jours d'observation pour
surveiller les indicateurs mais
différent qui a annoncé également que
les élus locaux avaient été consultés
pour l'évolution de ces zones d'alert
pour les villes dont je viens de vous
parler c'est évidemment en référence
notamment à l'imbroglio qui avait eu
lieu à marseille il y a de cela quelques
semaines olivier roncq a également tenu
à donner quelques points positifs lors
de cette conférence de presse il y a des
signes d'amélioration avec notamment une
inflexion positive à nice bordeaux
rennes ou encore à aix marseille propose
d'écouter ou l'hiver malgré ces
situations difficiles et c'est annonce
difficile
je tiens à préciser qu'il ya aussi des
signes d'amélioration dans plusieurs
endroits du territoire national il faut
aussi prendre des bonnes nouvelles quand
on peut les observer signe que les
mesures que nous mettons en oeuvre pour
lutter contre la circulation du virus et
que les mesures qui sont prises
d'ailleurs par les élus locaux de même
pour freiner la diffusion du virus sont
efficaces ainsi la nièvre et le morbihan
quittent leh départements classés en
zone d' alerte et on enregistre une
amélioration sensible de la situation
sanitaire
à nice à bordeaux une inflexion positive
également été observées à rennes ainsi
qu'à aix marseille
je le dis tout de suite avant de crier
victoire il faut avoir suffisamment de
recul être sûr que dans la durée
la circulation du virus se réduit et que
dans la durée
l'impact sanitaire sur les hôpitaux se
réduit il n'y a donc pas à date de
bascule dans une zone d' alerte
inférieurs pour les villes que j'ai
cités mais nous surveillons cela
quotidiennement et nous espérons pouvoir
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles peut-être
la semaine prochaine
et puis c'est donc bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie qui a pris la
parole un ministre qui a lui-même été
atteint par le cos vide et qui a
détaillé des mesures pour bien protéger
les salariés et les entreprises
ils vont le gouvernement va protéger les
entreprises les entreprises et les
salariés tant que la crise sanitaire
sera là c'est ce qu'a annoncé bruno le
maire ce soir avec notamment l'ajout de
75 mille entreprises qui pourront
désormais bénéficier du fonds de
solidarité alors vous l'avez compris la
volonté du gouvernement était donc de ne
pas communiquer uniquement sur des
mauvaises nouvelles mais l'information
essentielles à retenir c'est toutefois
la dégradation de la situation dans un
certain nombre de villes avec notamment
des services de réanimation qui
reçoivent à nouveau de nombreux malades
du cornât virus c'est le cas par exemple
en ile de france avec plus de 40 % des
lits de réanimation qui sont
actuellement occupés d'ailleurs la
situation dans la région inquiète
particulièrement les autorités puisque
ce matin le directeur de l'agencé
régionale de santé
il est craindre je cite une marée très
forte de nouveaux malades dans les
hôpitaux franciliens pour autant il ya
donc aussi des signes d'amélioration et
olivero indique qu'il n'est pas pour
l'heure question d'instaurer des
restrictions de déplacement en france
est une question qui revient souvent
puisque on approche des vacances de la
toussaint même si le ministre de la
santé
certes ne prévoit pas de restriction
déplacement il appelle toutefois à la
plus grande prudence
et du côté des chiffres sans paix
publique france annonce 18 1129
nouvelles contaminations aux copies de
19 ans 24 heures 77 personnes sont
décédées à l'hôpital
au total 1400 18 personnes sont en
réanimation doux
de plus que la veille soit un nouveau
record depuis mai mais le taux de
positivité des tests s'établit désormais
à 9,8 pour cent et pour revenir sur
cette situation sanitaire nous sommes
avec marie pierre martin elle est
infirmière aux urgences de l'hôpital
necker une chargée de communication du
collectif inter urgence un mari pierre
martin bonsoir merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors le plan
blanc a donc été déclenché à paris en
ile-de-france tension aussi dans
d'autres hôpitaux français comment vous
préparer à cette nouvelle marée annoncé
l'hôpital va-t-il tenir
on se prépare on se prépare comme on
peut l'hôpital va-t-il tenir
je lance un jeune personne n'y a déjà
pas tenu la première fois donc on verra
bien l'hôpital il faut savoir que
c'était intentions bien avant le coz id
c'était obtention bien avant on n'a pas
eu les changements dont on avait besoin
avec le ségur les syndicats signataires
ont pas du tout pris en compte les
besoins du terrain donc on se retrouve
dans une situation où malgré le ségur on
a daily qui continuent de fermer sur le
terrain on a des on a des soignants qui
sont épuisés qu'ils étaient épuisés déjà
avant qu'ils le sont encore plus on n'a
pas de reconnaissance on n'a pas eu tout
ce qu'on avait besoin c'est bien gentil
de nous dire qu'on au soutien mais à
côté de ça quand on vient voir et qu'on
dit qu'on a des réelles on n'a pas les
réponses qu'on a besoin
donc non la crise sanitaire nous a pas
aidé du tout et c'est pas du tout parce
que marie pia martin les accords du
ségur de la santé promettait des mesures
comme des embauches avec un montant de
plus de 8 milliards d'euros 1
donc ça veut dire que dans les faits
aujourd'hui vous n'observez rien ah non
non les embauchent elles sont pas là on
continue à avoir des démissions en
plaine
enfin on continue à voir des démissions
en masse à avoir des gens qui quittent
l'hôpital qui sans nom qui s'en vont
c'est impressionnant on continue à avoir
vraiment les gens quittent l'hôpital
tout ça on a des démissions les
fermetures de lits les conditions de
travail sont de pire en pire donc c'est
très compliqué alors avec le plan blanc
des interventions vont êtres vont devoir
être déprogrammée finalement nous voilà
au même niveau que durant le confinement
mais c'est même encore pire parce qu'en
fait pendant confinement on n'avait pas
les épidémies saisonnières là on arrive
en plein dedans on a la grippe on à la
gastro on allait les bons piaule it tous
les renforts qui avait été qu ils sont
venus en région parisienne dans le grand
est
il faut savoir que là on les aura pas
ils seront pas là la pédiatrie pourra
pas dépanner que ce soit en matériel ou
que ce soit en personnel parce qu'il ya
l'épidémie de bronchiolite qui est
arrivé les équipes les équipes sont déjà
à bout c'est déjà une période qui est
très tendue pour l'hôpital l'hiver et
donc avec le co vide ça va pas
s'améliorer alors olivier verrons ce
soir a réitéré son soutien au personnel
soignant
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
a qualifié votre profession
d'exceptionnel rappelant lui avoir été
touchées par la maladie
comment est-ce que vous recevez ces mots
d'encouragement ce soir c'est bien c'est
très gentil de nous soutenir
maintenant si quand on est en grève
depuis 18 mois et qu'on dit qu'il ya des
choses qui vont pas qu'on en a marre de
voir des patients qui passent des jours
entiers sur des brancards qui a des
hospitalisations brancards que l'hôpital
ne tient plus que l'hôpital est en
tension qu'on est en train de de vous
prendre ma langue ça en charge et en
soins la population française quand ça
fait 18 mois qu'on dit tout ça et qu'au
final il faut une crise sanitaire pour
comprendre que notre soutien on aimerait
bien avoir des mesures à la hauteur des
besoins de la population en santé
alors depuis la première vague vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure un de nombreux
soignants ont quitté leurs fonctions
qu'est ce que ça révèle au fond un
épuisement généralisé ou ou davantage d'
un écoeurement bas les deux je pense en
tout cas un les soignants sont épuisés
ça c'est à une
une chose qui est claire quand on a des
collègues qui racontent qu'ils ont plus
envie de voir les patients mourir sur
des brancards c'est une réalité c'est ce
qui s'est passé pendant la première
vague
c'est ce qui se passait déjà avant bien
avant le coup vide on avait déjà des
gens qui passaient 48 heures sur un
brancard aux urgences parce qu'il n'y
avait pas de place parce qu'on ferme des
lits parce qu'il ya déjà des soignants
qui s'en vont parce que la charge de
travail explosé parce qu'on n'a pas les
moyens et le temps de prendre en soins
aux patients correctement alors vous
appelé à une nouvelle manifestation jeu
sera le 15 octobre
quel sera le mot d'ordre ce sera le mot
d'ordre c'est là stop à l'hémorragie et
ses 2 2 se continuer à se battre pour
avoir un système de santé tels qu on
aimerait qu'ils soient et qu'ils
puissent prendre en charge la population
française de manière correcte et de
manière humaine
mais pour conclure cette dernière
question dans tendue le président de la
république emmanuel macron dire que ce
n'était pas forcément une question de
moyens mais plus une question
d'organisation
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez abbas et
c'est très bien c'est ce qu'on a dit
depuis 18 mois et on montre bien que
c'est pas ça c'était une question
d'organisation local ça ferait longtemps
que les hôpitaux ne seraient pas tous
d'accord là on est tous d'accord on
parle tous de la même voix on est tous
sur le même fait qu' il manque de lits
en manque de personnel on manque de
moyens on a besoin de moyens il faut
débloquer des moyens pour l'hôpital
sinon on se retrouve dans une situation
catastrophique comme on a pu la
connaître en mars et comme arrive prend
pas probablement dans les moyens merci
beaucoup
marie pierre martin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
infirmière aux urgences de l'hôpital
necker elle est chargée de communication
du collectif interurbain bars et cafés
fermés ville bouclée contacts sociaux
limités est les mesures restrictives se
multiplient partout ou presque en europe
à madrid par exemple le gouvernement
régional demande de ne pas quitter la
ville malgré une décision judiciaire
contraire françois xavier lambert des
chiffres de plus en plus inquiétants qui
touche même les pays qui semblaient
endiguer l'épidémie
en allemagne les autorités s'alarme
d'une deuxième vague avec un risque de
propagation incontrôlée le nombre de
contaminations de kobe de 19 a dépassé
mercredi la barre des 4000 cas
quotidiens pour la première fois depuis
début avril le ministre allemand de la
santé a appelé à ne pas gâcher le succès
du pays jusqu'ici dans le combat contre
le virus
malgré un regain de l'épidémie
l'allemagne reste proportionnellement
moins touché que ses voisins avec une
mortalité nettement inférieur la
situation est également inquiétante en
italie le gouvernement a décidé de
rendre obligatoire le port du masque à
l'extérieur sur tout le territoire et de
prolonger jusqu'au 31 janvier l'état
d'urgence le chef du gouvernement
giuseppe comté a souligné que l'italie
était entrée dans une phase nouvelle
avec une remontée des contagions ce
mercredi le pays a enregistré un sérieux
remous de l'épidémie avec 3678 nouveaux
cas soit un millier de plus en 24 heures
les mesures de restriction se renforçait
également en belgique fermeture ce matin
des cafés et bars sur tout le territoire
de la région de bruxelles
les restaurants peuvent en revanche
restés ouverts enfin la situation est
toujours très tendue en espagne où un
confinement partiel était entré en
vigueur vendredi soir à madrid et dans
neuf communes voisines des mesures qui
ont été rejetées par la justice
espagnole
un tribunal de la capitale a jugé
qu'elle était nuisible aux droits et
libertés fondamentales des quatre
millions et demi d'habitants concernés
gestion de la crise sanitaire procès
pour corruption la mobilisation contre
le premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou continue une manifestation a
encore eu lieu cette semaine malgré un
recond finement prolongé jusqu'à la fin
du mois et les restrictions liées au
rassemblement israël est le pays qui a
le taux d'infection hebdomadaire le plus
élevé au monde mais les mesures
sanitaires qui en découlent sont loin
d'être acceptées par tous notamment à
méa shéarim quartier juif ultra
orthodoxe de jérusalem dont les
habitants rejettent les mesures imposées
par le gouvernement émilie gouhier h
dans ce quartier juif ultra orthodoxe la
police est accueilli par des feux de
poubelles des jets de projectiles et les
protestations de manifestants ces
habitants de méa shéarim refuse les
restrictions sanitaires mis en place par
le gouvernement des mesures que la
police tente de faire respecter
amiel la fermeture de la synagogue
la police continue de patrouiller afin
d'appliquer les lois et la régulation
liés au kobus 19
chaque fois que de grandes
manifestations et les galons lieu nous
dispersons les gens nous avons eu
affaire à plusieurs funérailles où des
milliers de personnes étaient
rassemblées notre objectif est
d'empêcher la propagation du comité 19
au sein des communautés ultra
religieuses à travers le pays alors
qu'elles ne représentent que 10% de la
population du pays
la communauté juive ultra orthodoxe est
celle qui compte le plus de cas de
contamination pourtant ses membres ne
comprennent pas les restrictions
sanitaires et se sont pris pour cible je
pense qu'en vérité tout le monde veut
vraiment vaincre ce virus de la bonne
manière et en faisant ce qu'il faut je
n'ai rencontré aucun juif religieux qui
dit nous voulons être malade et nous
voulons attrapé le virus protestation
également de l'opposition les
restrictions liées aux rassemblements
sont ignorés pour pouvoir manifester
contre le premier ministre benyamin
nétanyahou en cause la gestion sanitaire
et économique de la pandémie mais aussi
son procès pour corruption
bien sûr netanyahu utilisent cette crise
pour conserver son siège pour éviter ce
procès et nous avons peur qu'ils soient
en train d'essayer de créer une guerre
civile entre nous il augmente
certainement la haine entre les
israëliens l'israëlien de droite et de
gauche ont commencé à se détester
mutuellement c'est vraiment dangereux
c'est quelqu'un de dangereux pour nous
je pense que pendant quatre ans nous
avons eu un bibi netanyahou un premier
ministre qui ne devrait pas être ici
parce qu'ils volent notre démocratie
c'est un voleur est un criminel
des manifestations contre benyamin
nétanyahou ont lieu chaque semaine
depuis le mois de juillet les
accusations de corruption sont rejetées
par le premier ministre dont le procès
est toujours en cours et pour en parler
nous sommes avec eux jacques benillouche
journaliste indépendant jacques bénigne
ou bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors on lisait les
israéliens continuent de manifester
contre la gestion économique et
sanitaire de la pandémie de kovy de 19
par le premier ministre benyamin
netanyahou alors la notion
d'acceptabilité elle est terminée là bas
je pense qu'il faut d'abord bien
distinguer les problèmes qui sont les
problèmes politiques les manifestations
politiques avec les problèmes se
sanitaire la population comprend des
problèmes sanitaires
la seule chose qu'elle demande c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas de discrimination ça
savoir que nous avons d'un côté là
l'impossibilité de d'ouvrir des marchés
de rue dans les rues ou en plein air et
de l'autre côté on autorise l'ouverture
des supermarchés ont interdit
l'ouverture des petits commerces
les petits commerces souffrent il n'y a
plus rien quand vous avez un commerce il
ya deux personnes en tout et pour tout
il n'y a pas de danger pour le
coronavirus et donc la population ne
comprend pas ces mesures qui sont qui
sont contraires à ce que demandent les
spécialistes vous savez qu'il ya un
comité de coronavirus dirigé par un
grand professeur qui est directeur aussi
de d'un grand hôpital israélien lui
demande à ce qu'on libère un petit peu
la la la la chape de plomb sur la le je
dirais la population de la même façon le
président de la banque d'israël ce n'est
pas n'importe qui et bien c'est lui
aussi a dit il faut il faut que nous à
es12 ayons un peu plus
deere pour que la population vivent et
enfin il n'y a pas plus tard qu'hier le
ministre kick ass qui est un ministre je
dirais très fidèle du likoud commence à
dire il faut que nous ayons quelques
mesures c'est pour ça donc il faut
comprendre que la population est lassé
de cette fermeture de ces fermetures
généraliser les commerces ferment et les
gens ne sont pas aidés comme on pourrait
le croire
comme en france il y à des endroits où
les magasins totalement mis la clé sous
la porte et ça c'est une chose qui est
dû aux coronavirus la population veut
bien accepter les mesures mais quand
elle voit que d'un autre côté les écoles
les écoles maternelles sont fermées ce
qui interdit alors aux parents au maire
d'aller travailler etc alors alors que
les écoles talmudiques de gens âgés par
rapport aux veaux par rapport aux petits
gamins de l'école et bien fonctionne
et lorsque vous expliquer justement ces
mesures de gouvernement comment vous
expliquez que ce gouvernement a du mal à
trouver un juste équilibre d'après ce
que vous nous racontez
et bien tout simplement parce que les
chefs des relevés les chefs religieux
sont au gouvernement
il constitue la coalition et ils sont
sans arrêt en train de faire des menaces
si vous nous interdisait d'ouvrir mes
écoles talmudiques
si nous nous interdisait de manifester
éventuellement dans certains cas et bien
auront la coalition et on quitte
gouvernement et benyamin nétanyahou
tombe donc là c'est un collègue un
chantage de la part des des dirigeants
religieux au gouvernement et c'est pour
ça donc les gens disent par exemple la
semaine dernière à iasi d'autres qui est
une ville du sud d'israël
il ya eu un rabbin quémande du coran la
virus il y avait 3000 jeunes 3000
personnes qui ont assisté au gala
l'enterrement les uns coller aux autres
et une grande partie d'entre eux refusé
de mettre le masque
donc c'est ce que dit la population d'un
côté on a des gens qui font ce qu'ils
veulent qu'il faut qu'ils vivent dans
une
de non droit vous savez en israël on a
détecté les endroits où il ya des
problèmes ce sont des villes la plupart
du temps et le ministère va dit
aujourd'hui il ya à peu près des quais
des quartiers entiers de religieux qui
refusent les décisions salutaires et
honteux on peut donc imaginer que s'il y
avait un gouvernement qui voulait faire
quelque chose eh bien ils apporteraient
des décider des mesures sanitaires pour
isoler ces clusters de deux corps d'un
virus et ça c'est une chose maintenant
le gouvernement a profité du conte à
venir us pour interdire les
manifestations vous savez en israël nous
sommes un pays en guerre et la
population n'a pas l'habitude de
manifester
de mémoire de journaliste il y a eu une
main des manifestations en 1971 contre
le lait par les marocains qui se
plaignait d'une discrimination en 2011
on a eu une manifestation la malle ce
qu'on a appelé la révolution des tentes
parce que les gens se plaignaient du
coût de la vie et du coût de
l'immobilier et là nous avons cette
manifestation où les gens se plaignent
de la situation économique de la
mauvaise gestion du coran la virus et
bien sûr il se plaît aussi de la façon
dont le dont on gère le la question
politique à savoir 1 un premier ministre
qui est inculpé et qui continue à vis à
à diriger le pays et donc ces deux
choses alors ces manifestants qu'est ce
qu'ils risquent en quelques mots il y à
des arrestations
iris à cenon une certains ont été
arrêtés dont un général ce qui est ce
qui a fait vraiment désordre parce que
on dit que ces manifestants
ces manifestants sont des anarchistes
n'est pas vrai il ya eu ou de barack est
un ancien premier ministre
il y a déjà des jeux des des généraux il
y à un ancien chef de la direction de la
police intérieure
donc ce ne sont pas des se sont pas des
mauvais esprits et y travailler il n'y a
pas de casque contrairement à ce qu'on
peut voir dans certains pays dans le
monde et bien donc là le problème c'est
que ces gens-là manifeste et le
gouvernement a interdit ces
manifestations si vous manifestez
et on vous colle une amende de 500
shekels à peu près 125 euros
parce que vous êtes plus de à plus de 1
km de chez vous mais là le gouvernement
a eu tout faux
parce que il a au contraire posé des
prix là au contraire étendu ces
manifestants les manifestants ont dit
très bien puisqu'on peut parler un jour
vous allez manifester
on va le faire chez nous et moi dans mon
petit coin dans une petit quartier de
chez moi de tel-aviv
et bien maintenant il ya presque tous
les jours des manifestants des gens qui
ne sont pas encartés
c'est des parents avec des enfants qui
viennent manifester et sa serai peu près
pan dont tout le pays donc on a voulu
faire le limiter là je dirais la
manifestation l'a étendu et on a poussé
des gens qui n'était pas encarté qu'il
manifestait jamais à venir et à
manifester et sentiments on entend bien
ce soir là la colère donc d'une grande
partie de la population d'israël comme
vous ne venez de nous le dire merci à
vous jacques benillouche je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste indépendante et
puis nous venons de l'apprendre la
dernière otage française encore détenu
dans le monde sofi petro n'a été libérée
comme vient de l'annoncer la présidence
du mali sur les réseaux sociaux
elle s'était également le cas de
soumaïla cissé hautes personnalités
maliennes
tous deux sont en route ce pour bamako
la bordelaise sophie petrona avait été
enlevée le 24 décembre 2016 par des
hommes armés à gao où elle dirigeait
depuis des années une organisation dead
à l'enfance et dans quelques instants
nous parlerons à nouveau du haut
karabagh des membres de la diaspora
arménienne se sont rassemblés devant
l'ambassade de turquie à paris pour
protester contre les affrontements
militaires puis direction la côte
d'ivoire la mission conjointe de la
cedeao l'union africaine et les nations
unies
pas se disent inquiètes de la situation
politique à moins d'un mois de
l'élection présidentielle
restez avec nous sur rt france
et
[Musique]
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que des chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme
c'est quoi le taux de fiabilité du
projet ne serait ce qu'au business et on
oscille entre 92 et 98 points 5 % elle
fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sur les coûts actuels
du pcr on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait on peut être
faire en sorte ofas appel à savoir faire
savoir faire médical aussi dans un
domaine un peu différente et celui de
l'animal mais après tout l'homme c'est
un animal peu plus tôt
[Musique]
le secteur de l'immobilier n'a pas été
épargnés par les mesures sanitaires
d'urgence mis en place par le
gouvernement les banques aujourd'hui
donc quand on sait qu'elles vont un peu
coupé les robinets et si elle coupe les
robinets ça va être un petit peu plus
compliqué pour l'immobilier l'immobilier
haut de gamme était la valeur refuge par
excellence celle qu'un qui a plus de 75
ans a priori l'achète pas un appartement
il le vent et comme il aura pas beaucoup
de retraite
il est assez probable qu'ils soient
obligés de vendre son actif pour
continuer à vivre
il ya un vieillissement de la population
qui fait que vous allez avoir une baisse
des prix dit aujourd'hui que c'est la
revente des campagnes contre les villes
parce que les villes souffrent
globalement tout le marché comme disent
les deux va devenir plus raisonnable les
acquéreurs vont être plus sélectifs
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et la préparer il
ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire en traîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter vert à 30% de son
pipe faut essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur nous
expliqué qu'effectivement le réveil va
être compliqué il va être douloureux il
ya eu un moment de très grand
relâchement et nous sommes en train de
payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous croyez qu'avec cette candidature du
pdc y votre parti reste crédible partir
du moment où le brizault rico nos
métiers revenir dans la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons plaide une malheureuse on peut
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
librement d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de nous allons
retrouver le pouvoir gagner cette
élection et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'avons pas les
poursuivre ou des fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près d ivoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française
un douzième jour d'affilée de conflits
au karabagh et parmi les infrastructures
touchées par les bombardements
une cathédrale historique arménienne à
l'établissement religieux visés par des
tirs azéri selon erevan qui évoque la
blessure d'un journaliste russe lors de
cette frappe
bakou dément si les affrontements
s'intensifient sur le terrain entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
les tractations commencent pour tenter
de trouver une issue les réunions
aujourd'hui à genève dans le cadre des
efforts menés par paris moscou et
washington
la présence en suisse du chef de la
diplomatie azérie son homologue arménien
est lui attendu lundi en russie
on écoute le premier ministre arménien
et le président turc vatan manche projet
cordato de richard strauss
quand des radicaux et des terroristes
internationaux sont là la région devient
une menace pour la sécurité du monde
entier
bien sûr l implication de la turquie a
une influence
il est évident que comme tout qu'on
voulait en fait si nous souhaitons
vraiment le résoudre des compromis sont
nécessaires comme promis nous voyons que
l'azerbaïdjan est extrêmement déterminé
à libérer son territoire
la turquie soutient de tout son coeur la
lutte légitime de l'azerbaïdjan pour
reprendre possession de son territoire
nous invitons tous les pays qui
défendent la justice et l'équité à
soutenir l'azerbaïdjan azerbaïdjanais
gros match aller et depuis moscou le
point sur la situation avec notre
correspondant en pointe cléroux dans
deux semaines de conflit pour l'instant
pas l'ombre d'une trêve à l'horizon
pourtant dans les coulisses la
diplomatie s'active aujourd'hui à genève
avait lieu une rencontre entre les
représentants du groupe de minsk c'est à
dire la france la russie et les
etats-unis et le ministre azerbaïdjanais
des affaires étrangères
alors cette réunion se tenait à huis
clos est rien
pour l'instant transpirer mais la
position de bakou est bien connue seul
un retrait des forces indépendantistes
arménienne pourrait mettre fin aux
hostilités à moscou aussi ça bouge
vladimir poutine s'entretient
régulièrement au téléphone avec le
premier ministre arménien et lundi c'est
le ministre arménien des affaires
étrangères qui est attendu dans la
capitale russe 11 au 13 octobre 2020 le
ministre arménien des affaires
étrangères au rabbinat de sakania
envisage de se rendre en visite
officielle à moscou le ministère russe
des affaires étrangères accueillera des
négociations entre les deux ministres au
cours desquelles sergueï lavrov et son
homologue arménien évoqueront les
problèmes internationaux et les
questions de sécurité régionale
bien évidemment l'accent sera mis sur la
situation extrêmement difficile dans la
zone de conflit du haut karabagh la
russie tente à titre national que dans
le cadre du groupe de minsk de l'osce se
déploie constamment tous les efforts
possibles afin d'obtenir un
cessez-le-feu immédiat est de réunir les
conditions nécessaires à la reprise des
négociations
on le voit la diplomatie est à l'oeuvre
que ce soit à genève aujourd'hui ou
encore à moscou en début de semaine
prochaine
d'ailleurs le kremlin n'écarte pas la
possibilité d'organiser à terme une
rencontre trilatérale même si ce n'est
pas d'actualité pour le moment
avec l'espoir que le dialogue entre les
nations parviennent à l' issue concrète
avec comme première étape indispensable
la conclusion d'un cessez-le-feu dans le
haut-karabagh la communauté arménienne
dia manifesté ce soir à paris devant
l'ambassade de turquie les précisions
sur place avec notre reporter katia
technique des milliers d'arméniens de
france et leurs soutiens se sont
regroupés aujourd'hui près de
l'ambassade de turquie à paris dans le
16ème arrondissement
il s'était déjà mobilisé la veille à
bruxelles ils étaient 5000 est
aujourd'hui dans le même temps il se
trouvait à marseille est également à
nice ils protestaient contre bas coût et
contre ankara pourquoi la turquie bien
parce que le pays est accusé de soutenir
les forces d'azerbaïdjan et soutenir
militairement mais également en envoyant
des djihadistes syriens alors les
manifestants aujourd'hui on prononçait
des slogans contraire doan et
l'expansionnisme turquie n'a eu des
prises de paroles également de diverses
personnalités
je vous propose de les écouter nous
voulons tout simplement l'arrêt des
combats
or à la barre et que
la france la france le président de la
république française emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron on reconnaisse
l'indépendance du radar à son juste
titre aux arméniens et que la paix
revienne
voilà c'est tout c'est une honte que ce
soit l'europe l'otan la france les pays
de l'accord de minsk c'est à dire les
états unis la russie et la france ne
fasse rien face à la destruction
programmée du haut karabagh surtout pour
ce qui est de la france
la france a déjà lâché les arméniens
pendant la guerre de cilicie et
l'arménie occidentale qu'occupe et yoann
parce que le traité de sèvres accordent
ces régions aux arméniens avec la
sentence du président wilson
donc c'est une occasion en or pour la
france de rattraper cette erreur
historique
la france aujourd'hui est en tête de ce
combat pour bloquer la turquie mais la
france est isolée
le problème c'est que l'europe continue
toujours comme d'habitude sa politique
ambiguë avec la turquie
l'europe n'a pas continuer à négocier
l'entrée de la turquie dans l'union
européenne et continue à donner un
milliard d'euros tous les ans à la
turquie dans le cadre de cette ouverture
là il n'y a pas de sanctions
internationales il n'ya pas de blocus
international
les arméniens de france appelle la
communauté internationale à se mobiliser
ainsi que la france pour que les combats
cessent au plus vite dans le
haut-karabagh ils prévoient d'autres
actions dans les jours qui viennent et
pour en parler nous sommes avec
hovhannès guevorkian représentant de la
république autoproclamée du
haut-karabagh en france
hovhannès guevorkian merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
va revenir sur cette cathédrale
arménienne de la ville de choucha qui a
été endommagé par des frappes selon
erevan
on le rappelle cette cathédrale avait
été reconstruite dans les années 90
après la première guerre du karabagh
devenant un symbole pour les arméniens
c'est un symbole terrible pour votre
communauté aujourd'hui alors aux vannes
est vivant qui on pardonne et moi nous
avons un problème de son on n'arrive pas
à bien vous entendre on va être
malheureusement obligés de stopper un
set cette interview
merci à vous et aux vannes s guevorkian
et donc nous allons poursuivre avec la
diplomatie internationale préoccupe et à
quelques semaines de l'élection
présidentielle en côte d'ivoire à la
cedeao l'union africaine et l'onu tire
la sonnette d'alarmé alors que le
scrutin est prévu le 31 octobre
en cause un contexte politique très
tendu seuls quatre candidats sur 44 ont
vu leur dossier être validés par la cour
constitutionnelle
parmi eux le président alassane ouattara
qui brigue un troisième mandat après
avoir modifié la constitution en août
dernier une quinzaine d'ivoiriens sont
morts en marge de manifestations anti
ouattara
la mission conjointe a exprimé sa vive
préoccupation quant à l'absence de
confiance entre les acteurs politiques
ivoiriens
elle a condamné fermement les actes de
violence et les discours de haine aux
relents communautaires qui se sont
malheureusement invité dans le champ de
la compétition politique et qui sont
susceptibles d'impacter négativement les
progrès réalisés jusqu'à ce jour dans le
pays
pour en parler nous sommes avec rodrigue
connaît il est sociologue et enseignant
au centre de recherche et d'action pour
la pêche
rodrigo et merci d'être avec nous sur rc
france alors la présidentielle du 31
octobre cedeao et l'union africaine
s'inquiète cet avis peut-il peser sur la
tenue du scrutin
est ce qu'un report est souhaitable
selon vous
alors voilà on a décidément quelques
soucis techniques ce soir ce sont les
aléas du direct nous n'entendons pas
correctement rodrigues connais on va
peut-être essayer une seconde fois de
vous reposer cette question
rodrick connaît si vous nous entendez la
présidentielle du 31 octobre je le
disais cedeao et l'union africaine
s'inquiète cet avis peut-il ne peser sur
le tenue du scrutin est ce qu'un report
est souhaitable selon vous rodrigue koné
est ce que vous nous entendez on essaye
alors malheureusement ça ne fonctionne
pas rodrigue connaît on va faire du coup
un retour en france
a toulouse plus précisément où la cgt et
la cfdt airbus appelaient à manifester
ce jeudi
le but protéger l'emploi dans le secteur
de l'aéronautique
une soixantaine de salariés ont
manifesté pendant environ une heure
devant les portes du constructeur
européen
ils demandent la suppression des
licenciements pour une application
massive de l'activité partielle de
longue durée est les syndicats veulent
faire pression avant l'accord du plan
d'adaptation qui doit être signé lundi
prochain en ce moment nous sommes à une
phase clé en fait tu du processus de
négociations l'accord ce qu'on appelle
l'accord du plan d'adaptation emilia
signature jusqu'à lundi prochain
et cet accord il entérine il entérine
d'abord d'une part la suppression des
emplois et ensuite la possibilité pour
airbus de procéder à des licenciements
secs et donc nous ici aujourd'hui on
manifeste pour protester contre cet
acompte contre cette suppression des
emplois
d'ailleurs à ce propos nous avons lancé
un appel unitaire aux autres
organisations syndicales pour en
particulier défendre l'utilisation de
l'activité partielle longue durée et
nous avons été rejoint sur cette
mobilisation par la cfdt
est ce qu'on conteste tout simplement
c'est la suppression des emplois la
suppression des emplois qui en fait
pénalise airbus dans sa capacité à
reprendre son activité plus tard et
empêche de de préparer le futur puisque
préparer le futur ça veut dire qu'on se
voir les futurs avions qui sont qui
seront compatibles avec la décarbonation
et puis je rappelle que pour le moment
nous avons
plus de 7500 avion dans le carnet de
commande qu'il va bien falloir produire
donc toutes ces charges de travail qui
est devant nous ce n'est pas en
supprimant des emplois qu'on va pouvoir
l'assumer
voilà on va pouvoir retrouver notre
invité aux noces d'or qui ont à propos
du 10e jour d'affilée du conflit au
karabagh et parmi les infrastructures
qui ont été touchés aujourd'hui par les
bombardements
une cathédrale historique arménienne a
on lisait il y à quelques instants
hovhannès guevorkian merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france cette destruction de
deux cathédrales c'est un symbole
terrible pour votre communauté
aujourd'hui naturellement la cathédrale
qui a été touchée aujourd'hui il fait
partie de notre patrimoine et le
territoire local wable ceux qui
connaissent un petit peur regorge
d'églises et de monastères qui date
depuis empêche de 4e siècle le siècle où
quand tous les arméniens quand toute
l'arménie a adopté le christianisme
comme religion d'état
c'est un c'est un symbole qui est
touchée effectivement à m'émouvoir par
ses frappes
la tactique la stratégie adoptée par les
forces azerbaïdjanaises
ce n'est pas une tactique militaire
c'est une tactique de terreur semer la
terreur par les descriptions chez la
population au karabagh qu'il faut que
cette population prenne le chemin de
l'exode
on va parfaitement que l'objectif de
l'azerbaïdjan dans cette guerre c'est
effectivement nettoyer des arméniens des
arméniens ces territoires à voir et
prendre possession de ce territoire sans
sa population on venait guibord qui ont
pardonné mois va être obligé de
d'interrompre cette interview nous avons
effectivement un problème de son que
nous n'arrivons pas à résoudre à nous
vous présentons nos excuses
on reviendra bien évidemment largement
dans nos prochaines éditions sur la
situation au karabagh et on va retourner
tout de suite
en côte d'ivoire on vous le disait il ya
quelques instants avec la présidentielle
du 31 octobre à la cedeao et l'union
africaine
s'inquiète alors on va en parler tout de
suite avec rodrigue connaît sociologue
et enseignant au centre de recherche
d'action pour la paix rodrigue connaît
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors est ce que vous nous entendez oui
je vous entends parfaitement alors la
présidentielle du 31 octobre
on le disait cedeao union africaine
s'inquiètent est-ce que cet avis peut
peser sur la tenue du scrutin
est ce qu'un report est souhaitable
selon vous la préoccupation de la cedeao
est tout à fait légitime parce que le
processus électoral tel qu'il s'est
déroulé dans un environnement de forts
clivages entre l'opposition et le parti
au pouvoir
les règles qui devait présider à
l'organisation de cette élection n'ont
pas été discuté de façon consensuelle
dans un environnement politique très
polarisée et très clivée pratiquement va
dire depuis la sortie de la crise de
2010 et depuis 2018 avec les claquements
de l'alliance qui était au pouvoir donc
c'est dans un environnement politique
délétère que pratiquement cette élection
les institutions étaient mises en place
donc montre aujourd'hui de façon claire
cette tension qu'il ya entre les
différents protagonistes
l'inquiétude de la cedeao est tout à
fait légitime parce que je dirais en
situation de crise cet acteur sur le
journal qui essaie de jouer les
médiateurs pour concilier les parties
mais la tension les positions sont
tellement tranché actuellement dans un
délai assez court la réalisation de ces
élections que l'inquiétude est tout à
fait légitime alors les opposants au
projet en candidats ont lancé un appel à
la désobéissance civile
un appel qui devrait débuter ce samedi à
quoi est-ce que l'on peut s'attendre
je pense que l'opposition elle-même n'a
pas clairement défini les modalités de
cette désobéissance civile si nous nous
référons historiquement à à cette
question de la désobéissance civile
on l'a vu en 2010 l'opposition je dirais
le parti aujourd'hui qui est au pouvoir
avait également lancé en son temps une
mode du désobéissance civile qui n'avait
véritablement pas également max et parce
que les populations ne savait pas
véritablement comment se positionner et
aujourd'hui on peut dire que
l'opposition lancement de boycott mais
sans en définir encore les modalités
normalement le meeting du samedi 10 qui
devrait se tenir au stade félix
houphouët boigny
c'est en ce moment les leaders voudrait
bien définir clairement quelles sont les
actions
ils ont d'ores et déjà avant d'annoncer
des fermes étude de marché des blocages
de d'approvisionnement d'ouvriers mais
concrètement sur le terrain cela reste
encore difficile difficilement visibles
difficile à appréhender par les
sympathisants de l'opposition alors
aucune confiance entre les différents
acteurs politiques ivoiriens selon un
communiqué de la mission
vous partagez cet avis il ya une
véritable crise de confiance entre les
acteurs
une véritable crise de confiance qui y
est comme gelée dit le reçu
de cette longue crise politique qui n'a
pas été soldés depuis 2010 et qui reste
véritablement une arène pour une scène
politique ivoirienne encore fracturée
donc là il ya une véritable prise de
conscience et la population ivoirienne
est ce qu'elles croient encore à la
tenue d'une élection impartiale et
transparente
les avis restent partagés mais
globalement on va dire que la population
elle marque son inquiétude
elle est comprise en otage par une
classe politique qui n'arrive pas à
résoudre ces problèmes
on va dire depuis plus d'une trentaine
d'années et donc elle est
malheureusement dans un état de
traumatisme relativement à cette crise
de 2010 et le sentiment partagé dans la
population est la volonté de ne pas
revivre encore cette situation de crise
là donc il ya des inquiétudes
il y a je dirais des appréhensions
d'un côté les sympathisants de l'un ou
de l'autre camp sont déterminés mais
globalement la population elle reste
après si on regarde dans le rétroviseur
le refus du président laurent gbagbo de
reconnaître sa défaite à la
présidentielle en 2010 cela a laissé des
traces
tout à fait tout à fait d'autant plus
que le processus de réconciliation
nationale at et juste après la crise n'a
véritablement pas soldé ce passé
douloureux
les mémoires est encore remarqué par
cette crise et qui a causé plus de 3000
morts et malheureusement la justice n'a
pas été rendue de façon très équitable
et de sorte qu'aujourd'hui encore les
camps au niveau politique en tout cas
reste encore fortement polarisé effet
totalement j'aiderai divisée laurent
gbagbo il pourrait avoir un avenir en
côte d'ivoire
c'est une question qui est véritablement
en plein de certitudes mais en même
temps je dirais que c'est un homme
politique dans la figure pèse encore
fortement sur le jeu politique actuelle
en côte d'ivoire quand des mêmes qui ne
soit pas dans un candidat retenu par la
cour constitutionnelle pour cette
élection
il reste une voix forte et influente
dans l'opposition et qui joue
indirectement eyrolles merci beaucoup
rodrigue connaît d'avoir partagé votre
analyse rappelle que vous êtes
sociologue et enseignant au centre de
recherche et d'action pour la paix
donald trump toujours positif aux
convives 19 les organisateurs du
prochain débat autour de la
présidentielle ont choisi qu'il sera
virtuel
les organisateurs estiment que ces
nouvelles règles vista je cite préserver
la santé et à garantir la sécurité de
tous les participants
donald trump qui a instantanément refusé
de participer à ce débat à distance qui
doit avoir lieu le 15 octobre prochain
il assure ne plus être contagieux à
l'actuel président des états unis a
déclaré je cite qu'il n'allait pas
perdre son temps avec ce débat virtuel
pour lui je cite débattre ce n'est pas
cela son rival démocrate joe biden a
également a réagi je vous propose de
l'écouter
nous ne savons pas ce que le président
va faire il change d'avis à chaque
seconde donc je ne peux pas commenter
cela serait irresponsable
je pense que je vais suivre la
recommandation de la commission s'il
refusait qu'il se prépare un meeting je
vais je ne sais pas ce que je vais faire
et c'est la fin de cette émission toutes
nos excuses pour les quelques soucis
techniques rencontrés ce soir mais on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour 1
point complet sur l'actualité a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter en partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche de l'intérêt de
leur population
ep
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vrai